this whole concept about withholding
taxes
right yesterday we're talking like it's
not really a big deal we're like we
gotta kind of come up with a better way
of putting it
withholding taxes how long has that
thing been around withholding taxes
in the first time ever where we well
withheld taxes
who was it under first time we ever win
that's easy that's easy that that's like
40 50 years ago some democratic
president give me a kennedy okay
lincoln was the first person that came
out with a withholding taxes
you gave essentially what they did is
they made the employer the tax collector
the employer became the tax collector to
see what they can do with the taxes
rather than the irs being a tax
collector
because they wanted to pay off the civil
war which they did and the american
people were okay with that because it
eventually what
stopped yeah it eventually stopped okay
but 1862 they don't have the adp system
they don't have all the system that they
have today it was simple the employer
kind of paid it to
the government right now fast forward so
that went away years later
guess who made it official to help tax
withholding system become a law easy
lyndon maine's johnson okay you know who
it is who
milton friedman huh out of all the
republicans
a republican so you know you know what
he said libertarian republican what was
he i would say he's republican i would
say he's republican by the way later on
in life when he did this it was in 1943
he was younger
he helped the reason why he says because
we have to pay off the world war ii
money
we just didn't have the money for it
right so they went from heaven this is
actually a very interesting
fact here they went from in 1939 how
many people in america do you think file
taxes in
1939. how many americans filed taxes in
1939 u.s population at the time was 131
million
yeah i'm going to say 20 million it's 50
million for four million people
wow there they go three years later they
go three years later
41 million they went from revenues being
900 million and 39
to five years later and 40 in 43 being
41 uh 43 billion dollars so think about
the amount of money they raised yeah but
that probably won world war ii
because of it but here's what happened
the difference is when it comes down to
taxes the following here's the
difference the difference is the fact
that
when they came up with the taxes in 1862
under lincoln they said it's going to go
away
when under wilson under woodrow wilson
they came out with the 16th amendment
the 16th amendment allowed people to
make
income taxes on law because before it
was tough you couldn't do it
the 16th amendment allowed politicians
to go back because there was this one
case
kind 1894 i want to say charles pollock
against farmers company of 1894
put charles [ __ ] i think it's versus
farmers of 1894 i think something like
that
type that in uh farmers okay there you
go click on that uh
1895. that was one off so charles
[ __ ] versus
pollock versus the farmer's loan and
trust of 1895
when they came up with this this they
were trying to tax the u.s population
four percent two percent
on four thousand dollars or more of
income he said no you can't do that
again it's against the constitution
the guy went and fought supreme court
defending him saying you're right
the constitution says you cannot just
tax people income taxes
so later on under wilson they made it a
lot the 16th amendment allowed the
government to just impose
impose any kind of taxes right now
here's a kicker
in 1913 when the woodrow wilson new
amendment came up
uh what happened to world war one when
did world war one start
1917. okay we got involved around 1917
1919.
do you know the taxes when woodrow
wilson first introduced the progressive
taxes
it was one percent for anybody making
zero to twenty thousand dollars
it was two percent for twenty to fifty
thousand dollars and it went all the way
up the top marginal tax rate
in 1913 was seven percent seven
percent not seventy percent four years
later the top marginal tax rate went to
67 percent
and you want to know something crazy
from 1917
till 1965
the top line top marginal tax rate never
went below 67 percent
all the way up to 94 is what happened in
taxes anyways i mean
the whole concept of taxes yeah
mind-boggling when you study what
happened here can i give you one number
sure okay
if you don't know this jump in if you do
maybe don't but
how many new irs agents does joe biden
want to hire
three times what we have today there's a
number exactly do you know what it is i
mean this is
unbelievable 87 000 irs agents man they
are going to be going nuts
you know they're they want to dig back
on all the other tax evasions that they
feel that people were guilty of as far
as high net worth people so they're
calling after that money trillion people
that's a lot
it's a lot all to do audits i mean
they're gonna be auditing like crazy
couple
so what what were your biggest takeaways
from what i understand
the tax correlation between taxes and
war yeah
can you can you pull up that link about
who's paying more taxes the one percent
the five percent the 10 percent if you
know which one i'm talking about can i
send it to you number two it doesn't
seem like this is a democratic
high taxation thing it seems like
republicans were taxing two
yeah but based on what you're saying the
difference is republicans did taxes
assuming it's temporary democrats made
it permanent
that's the difference and for specific
costs yeah so so lincoln said hey
let's raise taxes to pay off civil war
democrats said uh-huh
socialist labor party the populist party
the democratic party what if we can make
this permanent and they did
when milton friedman agreed to the tax
withholding system the only reason he
did
was because he thought it was to pay off
the world war ii debt that we had
he didn't think was going to be
permanent obviously he helped it become
permanent before he died in his memoir
he talked about one of the biggest
mistakes he ever made is helping pass
the tax withholding system really and he
said it was going to happen with or
without him but he helped that
can you pull up the numbers here kai
take a look at this so you know how we
talk about who pays the most taxes in
america you know we say
that one person's not paying taxes
anymore this is an interesting chart if
you make it bigger and flip the focus on
them
sam so this is the number of percentage
of taxpayers
the bottom 50 percent look how big it is
right then you get the top 25 to 50
percent then you got the top 10 look at
the bottom one percent
very small community right very small
community now
who pays the biggest amount of taxes in
america look at the right
the one percent pays nearly the same
amount of taxes as the bottom 50
pays look at the one percent right there
and then go to the next chart go to the
next chart that we had go
down i think it's a couple more keep
going keep going keep going is it above
it or below maybe it was above that kite
right there
make it a little smaller this shows over
the years
is the one percent paying more or less
taxes look at that
all the way to the left it shows you
from 1980
to today as the year goes by the one
percent keeps paying
more and more and more taxes
the top five percent is also paying more
and more
if you're into ten percent you're the
same nothing's changed for the top ten
percent
the top 25 it's getting lower the top 50
percent's getting lower
and a bottom 50 percent it's definitely
getting lower so this kind of tells when
you get into it and you take a deep dive
into the tax topic you realize it is not
as black and white as people talk about
it it's not like hey
you know republicans do this democrats
do there's no republicans also raise
taxes
but there was an intention behind it
with the payoff the democrats looked at
that and capitalized
let's make this permanent so again did
did you get the feeling after doing the
video that they could easily simplify
this
or this is okay yeah i think i think one
of the biggest
one of the biggest reasons why i did
this video is to get people to just
question
like what i want to see is the fun like
all right now look we got 1652 people
watching by the way let me just announce
this right now here's what we're doing
today
we got a couple new ideas that we came
up with anybody that puts a super chat
whether it's a dollar five dollars ten
dollars a hundred dollars whatever it
may be 500
by the end i'm gonna pick one or two or
three or five best super chat quotes
or questions that if we involve you and
we're gonna pay you back 10 times what
you put in super chat
for example you put 10 bucks what's 10
times 10 we're going to wire you
100 bucks you put 100 bucks if it's the
best super chat question
we're gonna wire you back uh what do you
call it a thousand dollars game because
when this is not a money-making machine
for us we're doing this podcast because
we're enjoying this
but at the same time we want more people
involved look at the 1690 people on it
right
okay do you know how many people like
this video goes out
in valuetainment but every time it's got
three million subscribers how many views
do you think the tax video is going to
get
honestly it's going to be one of those
that people share right you think so
i don't think so oh really that's the
problem what i think i think now if i
put a video
of me you know going out there and
jumping out of a plane it's probably
going to get a million views if i put a
video with me and a couple mobsters
it's probably going to get 100 million
views if i put a video about taxes and a
history of taxes
it's going to get probably 100 000 to
200 000 views over the next 12 months
why because
nobody cares nobody cares about taxes
they're entertained
they're watching netflix they're
watching sports there's a very small
community of people that are sitting
there saying this matters here's a pr
here's the challenge though
here's the good good news there you know
what the good news is if charles [ __ ]
could do what he did
and supreme court can go in his favor if
a story like this would lincoln which
you're a smart guy you went to a good
university
you did not know you're a smart guy you
didn't know i'm a pretty well-read guy i
didn't know this kind of stuff
i'm sitting here saying kai has read
half the books in the world he didn't
know any of this stuff right
we're sitting here going through this
date and we're like i never i never knew
about that
iris got started on their lincoln i
never knew about that you mean to tell
me
it was only for 10 years and then you
went away with it yeah because they
wanted to pay off the civil war
i never knew about that that's what
needs to be talked about the american
people need to sit there and say
wait what you mean to tell me federal
income taxes went away
yes how because we were living off of
excise and tariff taxes
that's what we were living off of right
it was 50 cents
per ton of goods coming from out of the
states foreign 50 cents per ton
and it was six cents per anything that
was being
exchanged within the states so there are
ways for us to change our taxes where
people from the outside are paying
there are ways we can change our taxes
and decrease it
but right now everybody's just kind of
looking away being entertained and taxes
keep going up and up and up and up and
up and we have no clue what the hell is
going on but
it's so many social programs that once
they have the money coming in they just
find new ways to spend it
that's the difference now right that's
why these things will never be lowered
once the politicians get a handle what
do you mean by social proof well i just
mean all the free
all the money that's going out all the
free money that's going on look what's
happened the last
few weeks so i mean that's where the tax
money's going that's why they want to
keep raising the taxes it's not like
they're looking
to cut spending cut anything in the
budget you know where the majority of
our
uh u.s budget goes the majority of our
budget are you going to say military it
is the defense
it is yeah well defense is not even in
the top five oh okay
what is it number one is social security
no no no no
entitlement programs that titleman's not
even in the top
20. i'm just saying where our actual
20 trillion dollar budget goes where
it's actually going the big three
social security medicare you pull out
okay
so we can look at this if you look at if
you google uh
us budget breakdown um the by far and
away it's social security
medicare medicaid it's not even close
and then after those big three things
you have um paying off our
there's one that has like a pie chart
kind of exactly pie chart go to the pie
chart
and then you have just paying off our
debt paying off our debt is probably
seven to eight percent then you have the
military and then all the social pro
programs that everyone thinks about look
healthcare defensively social security
defenses that might i think that might
not even be right go to a different one
point is the vast majority of our budget
goes to
old and sick people that's that's the
united states go up a little bit
discretionary spending so military
that's that's just a military that's
discretionary spending
just say overall anyway the point is
there it is right there social security
unemployment labor medicare health
medicare and health total mandatory
spending that we have yeah but
military's going to be different than
that
here's the point the point is if we keep
going the way we are and nobody
questions it we're just going to keep
coming up with new taxes
okay constantly coming up with new taxes
and eventually
here's another interesting fact for you
here's another interesting fact for you
which president increased the national
debt the most by percentage-wise
i'm going to guess lincoln he's
responsible for all of this give me a
lincoln
but in this part it's an ftr yeah it's
1075
which by the way was in 1930 you know
when he was
the new deal you know who's the second
you should be able to guess it it's 1916
who was the guy with the 16th
1913 who was the 16th amendment woodrow
what's good
he's second place okay he's second place
who do you think's dollar amount the
most
obama 8.8 trillion dollars you know
who's second place
trump it's very interesting when you
look at the numbers and see what's going
on
but percentage-wise fdr and woodrow
wilson changed
the entire tax system in america and
very few of us sit there and study about
it i don't know i just think there's an
opportunity for us to learn more yeah so
when it comes down to tax time and
voting we're going to vote in a
different way
this segment has been sponsored by turbo
tax if you have not done your taxes yet
turbo tax by the way
turbo tax is very thankful for even
saying their name right yes because now
some people actually think it is turbo
tax
it's actually not sponsored by turbo tax
it's sponsored by
um dvd tax no no what's the green
company the green light h r blocks
yeah neither one of them so if you
enjoyed this little short segment from
the podcast that we did here's another
short segment to watch
or if you want to see the entire podcast
click over here take care everybody
bye-bye
[Music]
you